míriam al Halak lives in a Berlin suburb
she's from Syria and part of a major
hunt to catch Syrian secret service
members who committed crimes like these
Maryam son Tom is one of the regime's
many victims he was beaten and tortured
to death when the Syrian civil war broke
out one of his fellow students even
health torture him he had always been
very courteous towards i''m and greeted
him I don't understand how someone could
turn into a torturer and become a
monster like that Syria's Secret Service
systematically tortured a young just for
speaking up for human rights demanding
Syria become a democratic country and
for urging Assad to step down now eight
years after AIIMS death his mother wants
justice I want the culprits to be
brought to justice
from the accomplices all the way up to
President Assad these people are
responsible for spilling our children's
blood there are more than 26,000
pictures of Syrian torture victims
smuggled out of the war-torn country by
a courageous former police photographer
they could help convict syrian torturers
and murderers in the coming years their
victims and their relatives demand
justice
like Syrian human rights lawyer Maz and
Darvish who was tortured before being
able to flee the Syrian capital Damascus
after a few months in the security
service and the branches you become
legless many of his friends and
political allies in the fight against
the Assad regime were abused like this
no one knows how many people lost their
lives
[Music]
so there is some there's AI goes a lot
before security branches I still
remember the lawyer shared all of his
information with European investigators
and has joined human rights
organizations in pressing charges
against former Syrian tormentors
european police are currently
investigating former assad torturers who
fled to Europe disguised as refugees in
February one suspect was arrested in
France and two others in Germany among
them Anwar who came to the German
capital Berlin as an asylum seeker
this is the first time it will be a tire
in these cases this is the first time
yeah this is a first time there is a
respectable independent court and judge
and we have victim and suspect and we
exercise the law and the state of law we
don't have it in Syria we have seen
documents showing that Germany's federal
office of Criminal Investigation has
investigated Anwar ours suspected
involvement with the Syrian Secret
Service we have asked the Syrian embassy
in Berlin for a statement it refused to
comment it could be that the prosecution
of Syrian torturers seems to be
gathering momentum in Europe we're at
the secret Investigative Bureau
somewhere in Europe where Bill Wiley of
the Commission of international justice
and accountability is working hard to
catch Syrian criminals he used to hunt
war criminals as a UN prosecutor now he
has access to a vast archive of Syrian
state documents that could prove crucial
and catching Assad's henchmen basically
what you have in this room are materials
generated by the Security Intelligence
structures of Syria the military
structures of Syria and the bath party
or political structures of Syria at the
top level and at the governor at levels
here they are the files documenting the
crimes of the Syrian regime they have
been meticulously cleaned scanned and
logged and carefully analyzed by several
dozen investigators the UN trials on
crimes committed in former Yugoslavia
and on the Rwandan genocide taught Wylie
one thing without a paper trail it is
very difficult to bring culprits to
justice that's why the Syrian state
documents which were smuggled out of the
country amid the tumultuous civil war
are so valuable they comprised
interrogation reports and many other
files that document figures within the
security apparatus that systematically
people they also shed light on suspected
Syrian torturers like Anwar are how many
of that type of people do you think that
we're aware of that more senior ranks
such as Anwar are there maybe more that
we're not aware but had difficulty aware
but knowing the documents could you
imagine it down
there could be more in Europe there's
certainly more outside of Syria whether
they're in Turkey or elsewhere in the
Middle East now Maryam Allah Allah whose
son I am was murdered by the Syrian
Secret Service hopes that not only the
killers of her son will be caught but
all perpetrators that have gone into
hiding will meet justice for her The
Hunt has just begun